All right Boris is out. Tory leadership
contest... what do you need to know?
the first thing you need to know and i think the
most important thing if you take away one thing
from this video is - it doesn't matter. it's not
going to affect you, it's not going to improve
your economic circumstances, it's not going to
fix the cost of living crisis, it's not going to
make it easier to pay your bills, it's not going
to make it easier to feed your family or to heat
your home this winter and i can explain why
in two simple numbers first number £450 billion
this is the total amount of money which has gone
from the government to the rich and the super rich
in the last two and a half years. Second number -
£15billion this is the total amount of money which
the government is offering to support ordinary
families through the cost of living crisis once you
account for the fact that they've raised your
taxes so let's compare these two numbers right
£450 billion that's £10,000 for every single
adult in the country all went to the rich so each
one of them is getting 100-200 thousand pounds
£15 billion well that's 30 times less so it's about
£300 for every adult in the country the key
thing to realize is the government caused a
£450 billion problem of inequality that money went
to the rich and now they're trying to fix it withjust
£15 billion pounds - 30 times less. the amount
of money gone from the government to the rich
is 30 times more than the amount of money they're
giving you to fix it what does that mean well
if you try putting a £15 billion pound sticking
plaster on a £450 billion pound wound basically
you're not going to fix the problem and none
of the tory leadership candidates and i suspect
probably no one in the tory party is serious
about fixing that problem if you want to fix that
problem you need to start taking serious amounts
of money from the rich and giving it to ordinary
people remember £450 billion would be £10,000
pounds for every single adult in the country
imagine if the government gave you £10,000cash
now how much that would help you well they've
done that for the rich and they're not going
to fix it okay so number one it doesn't matter
it's not going to fix your problems so stop paying
attention to it it's a circus these guys are
dancing around telling you they're going to help
you at the same time they're making themselves
richer and you poorer what should you be focusing on
you should be focusing on your money, your wealth
your family's money, your family's wealth, your
community's money, your community's wealth these
are the things you should be focusing on and this
is what you should be looking at okay if you're
old enough to have kids you should be looking
realistically at your financial situation and your
kids financial situation and you should be asking
yourself are my kids going to be able to live
in a better house than i live in now? are they
going to be able to afford to own more and better
quality property than i own? are they going tohave
a much much bigger mortgage than i ever hador
are they going to be able to afford to live agood
life without taking massive amounts of debt?
and if you're younger you should be comparing
yourself to your parents am i going to be able
to live in a better property than them? am i going
to be able to become richer than them in terms of
actual ownership of wealth? am i going to be able
to live a life without taking a massive mortgage
and i think if most of you look realistically you
are going to see that generation after generation
ordinary people are losing their homes and being
forced into more and more debt and you need to ask
yourself then okay well if we're losing our homes
where are the homes going who owns the homes now
those homes are not disappearing and if we're
getting into more and more and more debt well
who are we going into debt to you can't be in debt
to no one right if you are in debt then you are in
debt to somebody right so if we're losing ordinary
families in this country are losing their homes
and going into debt somebody has to be getting
richer and richer and richer because somebody has
to be owning that debt and owning those properties
and who is it well look in the last three years
what has happened right the average billionaire
has increased their wealth by 30 40 50 percent
unbelievably rapid increases in billionaire&
millionaire wealth, people like Rishi Sunak who
is one of the richest men in the countries
worth over £700 million pounds according to
the times rich list have massively massively
increased their wealth, while ordinary families
increasingly can't afford to turn their heating
on so here we have a situation where a political
party full of extremely wealthy people who
have presided over a system where they have
gotten massively richer during a crisis where half
the country can no longer afford to feed and heat
their families, are telling you don't worry guys
we've got this we're changing the face on the
label we're going to sort everything out, don't
believe it these guys are taking your assets
these guys are taking your homes these guys
are putting you into debt so turn it off
turn it off i don't care if his name is Rishi
or Penny or Kemi honestly i don't care none of
these guys are going to help you none of these
guys are going to help you but what it does show
is that these guys are organized okay they know
you don't trust Boris anymore so we're going to
put a new face on it we're going to put a new face
on it and we're going to tell you everything's
going to be fine they're organized they've got
a media strategy billionaires own the newspapers
and they're going to tell you look everything's
fine everything's going to get better and why
they tell you that because these guys are getting
richer and richer and richer by taking your assets
so of course they don't want you to push back
they're organized they've got a media strategy
they understand we need to change the
name on the label every now and again
to convince people that even though things are
getting worse now things are going to get better
well it's a lie you need to understand these guys
are super rich they have an organized strategy to
take your wealth so keep an eye on your wealth
your family's wealth and your community's wealth
make sure that instead of that wealth going to
them we're starting to get wealth back from them
and how do we do it well these guys
are organized they've got a strategy
they're trying to convince you that everything's
okay everything's going to get better you need to
be organized as well look these guys have the
money they own the media we are never going to
be as funded as them we're never going to own the
media like they do the only power we really have
is that there's more of us there's much more of
us but we only use that power if we act together
they want us to fight amongst each other and
argue over the little bit that is left for us
but if we come together and push back we can start
taking wealth and assets and money back from these
people but we can only do if we come together
so message to take away from this turn the tv
off ignore these people they're just selling you
lies but they're taking your houses the way to
take these houses back is to convince and educate
your friends your family and your community about
what's happening, we're losing our wealth they're
taking it, the only way to take it back is to unite
to understand and to push back and i'm trying
to do that here on this channel so please
share with your friends share with your
family and um yeah man let's get our
kids houses to live in because they're
gonna need them, thank you, keep watching